now I'd like to introduce our featured
presenters today Michael epic is an
associate professor of civil and
environmental engineering in the
Stanford engineering school
he's the faculty director above the
Stanford center for sustainable
development and global competitiveness
and Sanford's new smart city Research
Center in Songdo South Korea he is also
a senior fellow at Stanford's woods
Institute for the environment he says
the multi scale design construction and
operation of sustainable and smart film
environments my client is managing
director of force 12 ventures and an
adjunct professor of civil and
environmental engineering and management
science and engineering at Stanford
University he's a serial entrepreneur
who is founded over ten companies
including integrated systems RTI comm
West Light AI and SIA Tech Inc Mike has
been a general partner at five venture
capital funds including a co-founding
General Partner and zalga Venture
Partners Cambridge top five percentile
he was also a founding adjunct faculty
member of the Stanford engineering
entrepreneurship program Mike holds
degrees in engineering physics
Aeronautics and Astronautics and
Business Administration from Cornell
University Stanford University and
Pepperdine University Craig Schultz is
the chief executive officer of neo Prime
Inc a leading provider of cyber risk
reduction software and analytics he has
over 20 years in training and
development products in the areas of
massive scale business analytics
Enterprise Risk Management and national
technical platforms dr. Schultz was vice
president of product product development
for risk management solutions helping
the development of the largest global
risk platform with over a hundred
billion in insurance premiums for
institutional corporate Hurricane
terrorism earthquake and pandemic
exposure prior to that he spent 12 years
as a senior physicist leading special
modeling and nuclear risk reduction
initiatives at Lawrence Livermore
National Laboratory dr. Soares received
his PhD from MIT
in seismology benjin Bieber miss it
brings 27 years abroad and progressive
experience and applying leading-edge
technology to solving the most difficult
business challenges as sa peace global
vice president for the oil and gas
industry he is responsible for assuring
us a peace portfolio solutions and
services are meeting the industry's
needs and delivering the value expected
by industry executives he's leaning sa
peace solution strategy and global
marketing for the oil and gas industry
prior to joining s IP we bring the
served as a CIO of Snohomish County PD
where he was responsible for all IT
operations and cyber security during
that role he was recognized regionally
and nationally for his leadership as a
CIO and in cybersecurity and with that
I'm going to turn it over to Michael
laughing thanks Beth
you know we're really excited at the
department of civil and environmental
engineering to be to be offering both
this webinar and and a broader course
that we'll talk about a little bit later
the cybersecurity is one of the greatest
challenges of the current their work
environment and and the ways in which
cybersecurity affects the physical built
world which is our focuses is one that
we think is incredibly important and
that's why we're so excited to offer
this and so you know I'd like to turn it
over now to my client's to kind of walk
us through the schedule for today's
webinar and kick off the kickoff the
content Mike yeah thanks Mike
dough welcome everybody and very happy
to have you participating today and and
so the focus of today's webinar is to
give you a glimpse into what we're going
to do in the in the September course
which will explain a bit more detail in
toward the end of the webinar today will
give you a glimpse into what some of the
current attack vectors look like what
the impacts of code 19 are which as
you'll see quite significant
and then we'll we'll walk you through
the three stages of how we've organized
this program which is what do you do to
get set up in the pre attack mitigation
phase and this turns out to be really
important because if you do this right
it makes everything else much more
straightforward and if you don't well
and you have problems then we're going
to talk about shifting that into what it
looks like when you're doing response
management and what are the issues
associated with that and then what
happens for rapid recovery and what are
best practices there at the end of the
webinar will shift over and talk about
going deeper into all of these topics
and how the five session program is
going to work in the fall then to wrap
up we'll go into a little bit of Q&A and
try to answer your questions so now
let's talk about the whole area of pre
attack mitigation what is the best
approach for setting things up so that
you have fewer problems later on and
what we're going to do in this program
is approach cyber security from a
different angle than what you used to
seeing normally we're going to use what
Gartner calls financial integrated risk
management so what we're going to be
looking at here are ways to drive your
cyber security strategy from a business
impact point of view which is different
than the way most folks at associate
solving the cyber security problem by
just buying you know tools and things
from vendors and so on and saying hey we
got everything and we are protected so
why is business impact an important way
to look at that
and this these numbers kind of give you
the idea of what the problem is
so as you can see the spending on
cybersecurity solutions is becoming
rather absurd it's getting much much
bigger
yuria year-over-year and then you would
think okay with more and more techniques
and tools and spending we should be able
to suppress losses but that's not what's
happening the cybercrime losses are just
getting worse and worse and so in some
ways one could say that the losses are
correlated with increased spending on
this I mean certainly it looks like that
and this has really now become a multi
trillion dollar problem and what it says
is that the solutions being deployed
don't work and so that's the obvious
conclusion for this and the question is
why is that and so I'm going to turn
this over now that Cray so he can dive
into more details around why this
doesn't work great yeah thank you Mike
and as Mike said you know the focus of
the course is on the three different
stages of attack and losses occur in
each of these stages and can occur to
different levels and so really
understanding business impact in each of
those stages is a primary focus of the
course and its curriculum here and of
course minimizing attacker free time as
we call it the amount of time that
attack there's actually within the
system is a key element in reducing
business impact so it didn't if we go
forward and kind of look at threats
today the course is not focused on
threats in general but really on what
are the what's the current threat
profile as of the time of the court and
so as we've all experienced right now
COBIT is that a fairly significant
impact on everyone from a
cyber perspective shown here is some of
the Trend Micro statistics for q1 of
this year and you can see how the
dramatic increase in how attackers have
really dynamically changed to target
businesses based on current
circumstances and the key takeaway here
is that cyber risk and business impact
has not become kind of an it's no longer
really an annual assessment thing it's
something that actually has to be
managed and almost a daily basis the
COBIT case risks to corporation changed
overnight and it has dynamically changed
and in the attacks that we've seen
dynamically change every week since the
Cova you know the Kovach pandemic that
started and it's it's morphed into
different forms so really the key
takeaway here and for the course is how
we manage risk around the current
profile and do this on an ongoing basis
the second part of the course really
looked at how you manage infrastructure
if you look at the statistics on the
left here you see from Gartner kind of
the current pre kovin focus of
infrastructure and security now this
profile is changing dramatically right
now and what we've seen is a number of
things and I'm sure everyone on Collier
is witnessing parts of this which is
really the migration to mobile workforce
people at home not necessarily in
corporate systems for instance operating
off of personal systems in some cases
the other one that not so many people
are familiar with is is the mass
migration to the cloud and we've seen
and in particular infrastructure as a
service increased an uptick by over 20
percent just in the last few months as
Kovac has occurred and the question is
you know what are the what are the
ramifications from a risk perspective of
migrating to the cloud so quickly in
some cases companies do this just over a
period of a week or two you know and
migrated to a platform that prior to
kovat I you know they were under intense
discussions the security and risk
implication I combined with this the
fact that you know there's loss of
revenue and you may not have as much
capital and so cost now is a much higher
focus and so the course here is really
focused not only just on the risk from
cyber but the trade-off the cost the
trade-offs of business impact and and
productivity for the company has to
operate kind of this changing risk
effect and the course will focus beyond
that on some of the emerging malware
sets and really be immersive in the
current attack at the time of the court
to attack just as examples here that are
quite relevant to this discussion
the Baltimore attack where essentially
nation-state reverse-engineered malware
and called Robin Hood was used to attack
the city the city was down for over a
month this was a ransom or attack asking
for about eighty thousand dollars
Baltimore did not pay the resulting
losses then were more around eighteen
million dollars or so and their trade up
right in terms of how you actually
respond and manage these event the other
thing to note here is that insurance
played a key role and that malware set
and lack of insurance added some more
losses and so not only are we looking at
cyber attacks but in the physical
economy you're really talking about
tying you know physical systems to
insurance to business continuity and
operation and then back to the cyber
impact the second as an example second
set of malware you know of interest
especially in this energy utility
sectors are things such as crash
overwrite and why do I mention this if
you if you look closely at the at the
cert for this the us-cert crash override
which has been out for a while we're
seeing what I call almost a new category
of malware that when you look at it and
you read the sentence here you see
that us-cert is basically saying that
current security controls cannot defend
against this this malware set and as a
result as we've seen it's quite
effective at getting into ot systems and
so this raises the question about how do
you really manage your business risk
when you have malware that can bypass a
very effectively bypass existing control
system meaning that compliance and other
items like that are not effective at
reducing impact and so a key element of
the course will be looking at how to
manage against risk an event that that
that compliance and certification really
do not have an impact on which is a
reality of today risk management
environment and so with that I'll turn
it back over here to Mike to go through
kind of basic questions and how we
manage these risks within the course
yeah thanks Craig now I think we're
going to get here a more on the ground
sentiment on these questions from
Benjamin because the managing the risk
in an effective the way really requires
that you be able to answer a bunch of
questions
Benjamin you want to take us through
some of these questions and opine on
them and whether folks can actually
answer them now yeah I think what's
interesting about these questions is
that when you're a CIO or you're a CEO
or you're someone on a board or even the
chief information security officer I
think these are questions that you are
constantly being either asked or asking
and when they're you know your answer
today is going to change tomorrow just
as Craig was going through some of those
examples
so the Ukraine event happened one I was
at my previous role it's 90
responsible for cybersecurity not only
for snow ped that eyes also representing
all of American public power with Newark
which is the federal age Energy
Regulatory Commission for governing
these the utilities in the US and what
was interesting is that you know the way
I would answer these questions before
that event and after changed I think
that's the point that we're we're trying
to make here is when you're managing
security it's constantly changing and
you need to look at this and understand
you know how do I make the right
investments you know you're going to
your board asking for money constantly
saw the numbers from Mike earlier
billions of dollars are being spent on
cyber security how do you know if you're
making the right investments a lot of
times companies are focusing on building
higher thicker walls to try to vent
people from coming in but that's not
always where the right investment needs
to be made and I think understanding
where your opportunities are what your
threats are and how you can get the most
value out of your investments is really
well we would like to help people
understand and help people comprehend
where those opportunities to offer for
them well yeah then a question that
comes up certainly in in when you're
going through this list is why don't see
suite and you know managing directors of
corporations just do what the cisco says
and the cio says and that's it well I
think you know we'll talk about this
little bit later as well but I think
it's about understanding the
ramifications of your decisions right
it's about understanding where or how
you're going to impact your operations
with some of those decisions but in
Craig got some good ideas here on
starting to look at how how we can look
at those risks and those financial
factors that have a more comprehensive
view of how to make the right decisions
for your cybersecurity program and your
strategy as a whole yeah absolutely
Benjamin and if you look at the slides
up right now you know there's kind of a
range of techniques the more
one has been risk scoring and fuel gauge
and we'll cover these in the course and
there's been a steady migration of new
technologies which is very exciting you
know and so you're seeing kind of the
emergence of technologies that are
starting to try and get a better idea of
what business impact is you know from
changes in security controls and
initiatives within the organization you
have kind of the financial factor
analysis which tries to put a larger
bound on what the financial impact is to
give general guidance and even more
exciting is kind of the scenario pathway
testing which allows you actually look
at your system and how it responds
that's said these technologies
independently really are still not
enough because if you just look at them
they really they really don't look
antibac pathways to the business impact
which is what really needs to be done to
understand the red and so in this course
now that we're going to focus on these
techniques but we're going to go to the
next level and and and really look at
this from kind of the c-suite and board
level and how you really start to tie
business impact and business
decision-making back into pathway
analysis and back into kind of
forward-looking blueprints and templates
for what can happen to the company and
that then allows transparency at the
leadership level so I'll be a major
focus at this Court is looking at how
you tie business continuity operations
the physical security elegance and bring
these all together in terms of what the
impact is on the company and then be
able to demonstrate impact by the
investment that you do and look at
return on investment from your security
controllers so if we go on I think it'd
be good right now to go through
essentially a case study similar to what
we'll do in the course and and Benjamin
having been it's no cut has has
witnessed this firsthand so Benjamin
will turn back to you and talk about you
know one one one kind of immersive case
study here yes Thanks so as part of my
work at snowfoot I was always trying to
figure out where are our opportunities
and where our weak points
and one of the approaches you can take
is have someone do an ethical half of a
pack of your company or pen test of your
company so we actually hired the Air
Force and Army National Guard to do that
for us so that was an interesting
activity one of itself had they actually
get the governor of the state of
Washington to approve this but what was
really interesting if these gentlemen
were extremely amazing talented
individuals they you know they all had
day jobs working for major companies
like Microsoft and t-mobile but there
are some of the best trained cyber
security experts you'll ever find being
trained by the US government as well and
so my team felt we and we've been you
know evaluated and thought we had a very
strong cybersecurity program until we
went through this exercise and you can
see here it's a very simple path right
they did some fishing of users that
happen within about 20 minutes they're
able to get in and start to get access
to our systems and I can go through the
entire chain here you can read through
yourself but fundamentally we had what
we called a smart grid lab which was set
up to mimic our control systems for a
production environment of managing the
grid there in the northwest and that was
their target right if you like capture
the flag that was the flag thereafter
and they were able to get there it was
very interesting about going through
this exercise was one the team didn't
think it was possible in fact they
thought I gave those little keys they
felt I gave them those keys to the
hackers to help them through and I did
not and so we actually had the team that
did the hacking in pen test go through
step by step how they are able to get
from entry all the way into our critical
systems understanding that was an
eye-opener and I think one of the first
things you always have to remember in
cybersecurity is there is no way to
prevent a one number seven
you know hybrid cyberattack you know I
always joked that my personal
information has been stolen so many
times I had a security background with
that was done by the FBI and
and NSA and those folks and CIA and all
them you know that better information
was a stolen at one point so I think you
know that's one thing is you we're
having conversations with a board with
our leaders they have to understand
there's no way that we can 100% protect
the company it's about making the right
investments and it's also about having
the right response plan when we do have
those events and so it was a very
interesting experience
there's several white papers written on
this can be shared as well that's great
thanks Benjamin yeah and so you know
from the standpoint of you know looking
at the attacks it seems pretty simple
that attack paths it's quite common
between most attacks that Benjamin just
walked through and it seems like the
purview should be pretty simple to pick
up on that pathway to protect against it
so the complexity here is that is you
know is that isn't just one pathway what
you're looking at here is is a simple
corporate structure for a system that's
running on the order of about a thousand
computers so this is a small company
small to medium company and what you can
see here are the access pathways through
that system and and the number that even
for a small company you have to look at
in order to figure out the pathways true
and many of these are potentially viable
pathways to take over the entire network
which is the the node that's on the far
right essentially the active directory
system you add to this what we see with
many companies which is the fact that in
order to monitor this and and if course
you get to a global multinational
company you're talking about you know a
system that's hundreds if not thousands
of times larger than this and the amount
of data you know for a large oil and gas
company or for you know a particular
financial company easily reaches
terabytes of data coming through this
system per hour and and so trying to
monitor the system and all of the
different pathways through it
is a very difficult daunting
and yet to that the false alarms coming
off on kind of these critical
infrastructure systems and and you can
see from a cost-effective point of view
it can be quite you know quite difficult
and so and so how do you actually you
know protect this system the traditional
approach right now that we've seen with
companies is is to actually you know use
monitoring systems and and of course try
to put in security controls in the
general way from a compliance standpoint
that try to try to impact this the issue
is that from the shotgun approach your
monitoring tremendous amounts of
information it's large teams to do this
and this is where cost becomes an issue
if you try to monitor everything becomes
difficult to actually protect the system
and if you look at the attacker coming
through they obviously have their very
specific pathways that they're targeting
on and each attacker you know has their
own favorite so so they'll be coming
from different directions based on the
malware that they have and and so one
way and to to actually mitigate this and
to reduce costs is to really look at
which of these pathways I have the
largest business impact on the compass
and focused in on the pathways that lead
to largest dam and so in this case
you're looking for one threat group with
their malware set and you're seeing
what's the most damaging pathway is from
this front from this group in this case
you can actually start to now prioritize
and look at how you might introduce
security controls to impact that and so
in this case you can actually look at
the different nodes look at the staging
that they might do and and the problem
becomes much more tractable from a risk
management point of view and so in the
end if you know the pathway and you know
the various staging mechanisms you can
win target security controls in the
physical security area against the
specific eye damage pathway this is
really integrating kind of the concept
of risk management with how you
implement security controls and then
costs become you know the critical
driving factor
the prioritize in this manner becomes
absolutely crucial you know to how you
how you manage the system so there's
really at the core of business impact
modeling and how that can reduce cost
and also at the same time give me a good
understanding of what the final business
impact is on the company so that c-suite
board members have transparency for that
effect so if we go beyond that I'm going
to turn this back over but now that you
can understand you know how risk
prioritization can help in managing you
know highly complex systems like cyber
access control and other things like
that
turn back over now it kind of the view
that c-suite and and and board members
can get if you start to position
analysis or risk analysis in this manner
yeah so it was very interesting because
of all the dynamics that Craig was
talking about and your executive team is
going off the conferences and and in the
oil gas industrial utility industry
cybersecurity is one of the top topics
that are talked about and it was they
come back and they started asking you
all these questions how would we know
we're making the right investments etc
and so it was really good working with
the team to come up with a way to look
at this and a simple way to make the
right decisions and if you look at this
chart on the left hand side here right
really to our point of understanding the
business impact and when I sat down with
our board I said I really want to talk
about two things with you I talked about
cybersecurity the first is the
probability of an attack and the second
is the impact of that attack and my goal
and everything we do from an IT
perspective or security perspective
should be focusing on those two numbers
so build a display to them
this here's what our plan is going to be
so the controls are across the bottom we
had not only regulatory requirements
kind of coming out of the federal
government but we also had assessment
done by by the neo
solution here and then we also had other
input from our hacking pen testing that
we did with the National Guard all those
so I had all this information and I
needed a way to figure out how do I make
the right steps I don't make those right
investments where I get the most bang
for my buck where should I start looking
to maybe apply insurance which wasn't
part of our risk mitigation plan at the
time so if you look at this across the
top you have the risk reduction numbers
a percentage of the risk reduction
number then you have the controls across
the bottom so if you look at asset DLP
is an example you I get the most bang
for my buck because I'm going to get the
largest percentage of decrease and or
what a larger percentage of decreases in
the three-year reduction but also I see
a overall reduction my overall risk
profile by fifteen percent as well not
only am i reducing my cost but also
reducing my risk profile as a whole so
that made it very easy for me to go into
the board and say hey we're going to go
off and spend X dollars we're going to
implement these controls and then
implement that and build and then show
value back to them from a risk reduction
perspective perfect Benjamin and then
and then in addition to that going back
to the questions Benjamin that you
introduced at the beginning you know we
know it's challenging to answer those
questions such as what is what is the
top control that most reduces my
business impact you know from a cyber
perspective and so you know using times
like this you actually can you know take
the next step and now you have the
answer to that question at some level
and and allows you to give you
transparency because in this case you
know you can actually say here's the top
control measure that actually reduces my
risk of loss and when you start doing it
it kind of forces one to you know think
in a structured way because when you
break down the analytics you know at the
higher level of the company
it forces you to actually look at your
recurrence period so in this case you
see that acid LT is the most impactful
control for your recurring losses over
three years so on average over the next
three years as the deal he will reduce
my risk of loss the most as a company
now interestingly enough if you go here
and look at your 20-year we bring lots
look at this like you know your 20-year
hurricane recurrence your New Orleans
but your 20-year recurrence lost if you
click on that actually go through and
start to look at it what you see is
these controls tipped around many times
and dramatic weight and so if you're
trying to mitigate your longer-term
20-year loss it's very different
controls and those are typically your
nation-state controls where as you see
the three-year loss down below here is
primarily criminal organization they're
the ones you're going to impact the
treaty loss so it forces you to start
looking at you know what are you trying
to mitigate with the security control
and then finally it does give you a way
to start looking at insurance because
the residual risk that's left after
implementing these controls then gives
you a target a quantitative goal and
target in terms of risk transfer so if
so so that's risk minimization and
obviously that's the loss reduction
shown in green here but there are many
other aspects that companies are faced
with one obviously being cost reduction
when you're actually trying to figure
out the initiatives and the controls
that you implement how much you spend on
cyber security for that year and so I'm
going to turn this over to Benjamin to
talk a little more about the the breadth
of trade offs and and how you approached
it yeah I'm just going to use an analogy
just to kind of clarify the point we're
trying to make so we talked a lot about
loss reduction and cost and if you just
take a company like Nordstrom who is
very both employer focus as well as
customer focus and if you think if they
added some security features to their
overall program because they have lost
reduction right people are stealing from
them on a constant basis if they all of
a sudden started to
to Pat you down as a customer every time
you left the store right my customer
experience would go way down my employee
experience and having to do that would
probably go way down and the cost for
the company would go way up so there's
got to be a good balance between the
costs the corporate productivity your
operations and the impact on your
employees getting their jobs done and
balancing that all out is very
interesting we did this with our when
our generation facilities had to be
upgraded to meet Newark ships compliance
we had to go out and help them
understand that and then help us
understand this well how do we reduce
the impact on their operations but make
sure we put in the right controls in
place to keep the facilities secure so
it's a balancing act to try to manage
this across those dynamics thanks
Benjamin it's yeah that's a great
example and and so now one of the things
that you need to take care of here is is
the whole structuring of corporate
security roles and responsibilities
Benjamin touched on some of this
material over the last few minutes well
one of the things that you know many
operations don't do well is have a
really fully articulated playbook about
you know how this is going to work and
you know who's responsible for what and
in each stage of the operation
you know pre mitigating what's going to
happen really understanding the whole
playbook
who's responsible for controlling the
security for communicating for making
these business decisions that affect the
business continuity and the cost for the
company going forward that this needs to
be really carefully laid out and
we're gonna dive into that material even
more later now in with respect to that
we need to focus as you can see when you
go back to the financial integrated risk
management approach to controlling the
whole security posture of the company
it's really about these top two things
the corporate return on investment a
systems approach to what it's going to
cost to actually make the company secure
and to sustain operations and the whole
thing needs to be business impact driven
whereas in many cases right now it it is
not done that way it's it's more of a
technology oriented approach to
controlling security you know and what
is the latest hot product or bell and
whistle or something that has some
compelling technology advantage that
says yeah we can detect everything and
and I think as you've already seen
that's not really possible these days
with a IML driven solutions the
attackers are gaining even more
advantages because they're using those
technologies against us and yeah those
technologies for sure are being used to
advance cybersecurity products but the
attackers are also using them and in
some cases more effectively than the
defenders and so this can't just be
driven by technology that's not going to
work
so the emphasis is corporate ROI
and business impact that's that's the
approach that we're taking and is in
this program so one thing we can look at
is in the next phase is what happens
when we're responding to an attack
that's happened
very much like what Benjamin laid out a
little bit earlier and one of the key
elements of this is crisis communication
we're going to have extensive sessions
on crisis communication and it's it's
very much making sense of what happened
because as it says if we can't make
sense of actually what happened then
someone else is going to make sense of
it and one of the key things here that
distinguishes cyber response from say
dealing with natural disasters like
hurricanes earthquakes and so on as
Craig mentioned earlier is that those
those events don't don't do anything
differently depending upon what we do
there they're just what they are
whereas in cyber attacks the behavior of
the attackers is heavily driven by what
we do and and they're paying attention
to how we communicate as well and you
know this also brings in the notion of
oh yeah we're just compliant struck
that's all we do and if the attackers
know how we're complying with NIST and
other standards
this is tremendous information for them
and dramatically in some cases drives
what they do to attack us and our
behavior is going to drive though what
they do next because these attacks as
you saw earlier can go on for quite some
time this is not just a one point in
time kind of event okay and the crisis
communication strategy has to think
about all of those elements and there
are certain roles and responsibilities
and who communicates what and when and
how is it's really critically
necessary to manage this properly now if
we shift to the recovery part of this
I'm going to turn that over to Craig to
talk about some of the elements we need
to address when we're recovering perfect
thanks Mike and building on some of my
comments recovery similar in some ways
to response but it's quite interesting
here is when you move and and extend
beyond compliance to business impact
driven management a couple things really
stand out in terms of reducing losses to
the business as a whole just to
highlight a few here I basically the
removal of malware is something that
typically leads to heavy loss with
companies the lansing michigan case
where the utility there in michigan was
taken down they tried to rebuild their
systems multiple times the malware was
not entirely removed and as a result
they had extreme cost and eventually had
to replace most of their systems of
product across the entire corporation so
quite quickly you see that you know
understanding when malware and verifying
that malware is removed becomes a
critical business loss issue the second
item I'll mention just to highlight this
is is the changing threat landscape you
saw the attack graft that I showed
earlier those are actually from an
offensive attack tool and so you can see
them mapping that that group already has
of the system that they attack they have
a very good idea in some cases better
than the security personnel themselves
in the company and so this threat is now
staging is in a position to stage
against the company in the future so
really really what your threat profile
is given that the attack just occurred
and looking forward at that to
understand it becomes critical in
reducing loss the final one I'll mention
coming back to Baltimore is really
taking a more careful quantitative
financial look at your insurance and
really being able to assure shareholders
and stakeholders that that your
insurance does coverage cover the types
of attacks that your
to see and really taking a relook at
that to make sure that that the the
company has proper insurance and risk or
other risk transfer mechanisms in place
so as you can see you know looking at
this from the business impact point of
view really changes some of the items as
a company that you might focus on in
addition to compliance not instead of
but in addition you can find to really
secure physical as well as as well the
other digital system that you're working
yeah thanks great so we can we can get
some key takeaways now and kind of
summarize the things we've been talking
about for the last 45 minutes
is that the key thesis here is that it's
no limits pending against cyber threats
really doesn't work anymore the spending
and the selection of controls that are
needed is very situationally dependent
its path dependent and it depends on
what's going on in the threat
environment and this is as greg pointed
out something that actually needs to be
tracked you know almost daily to be
really really effective okay and it's
also clear that transparency is
necessary in communication not only so
that the c-suite can properly control
the risk in the company but you know
that were compliant you know on the
regulatory side and and those and those
regulatory requirements are getting
tighter and stiffer you know as time
goes on and the penalties for failure to
do this properly are becoming more
severe we need blueprints and playbooks
for how this needs to be handled and
communicated and the you know
the key issue here is that we need to
keep coming back to this notion of
business impact and that compliance per
se isn't really the solution and in fact
in many instances it's fairly
straightforward to show that being fully
compliant is actually not correlated
with risk of loss and and you know and
that's certainly a disturbing situation
for sure so now what I'd like to do is
is shift over and and in the remaining
few minutes here just really quickly
talk about what we're going to do in the
20 hour program in September and and the
focus or the the attendance for this
program is really driven around c-suites
the board of directors senior managers
and and not per se scissors or people
who are you know deepen the technology
for how they're actually going to
implement the solutions but this is more
of a higher-level
set of folks that need to understand how
to control the business risk because
that's going to be the principal focus
and what we're gonna do is give a very
real-world scenario based education here
where we're actually dealing with
something that replicates what they
might see in in real life and the key
point here is going to be how do I know
when I've spent enough money when am i
when am I done or what is my process
going to look like here because my
budgets are not going to be unlimited
and I've got to pay attention to the ROI
and so we're going to be as we said very
immersive in this probably in this
program and and we're going to
look at a kind of a fictitious standard
energy company in this program and the
network's for that company are going to
be quite elaborate we're going to be
using large network emulations to
illustrate the various points and the
risk of loss and the loss pathways in
the system and we'll also use that to
drive the pre attack mitigation
strategies you know what are we doing to
get everything set up and then we'll go
through some actual attacks that have
happened to utilities and you know other
physical type systems to see what they
actually look like and and show how all
of that is communicated to the feast
week and the C's we will need to be able
to respond to those things and do crisis
communication and all of that sort of
thing and we'll be practicing this
throughout the course so that we
understand actually what it looks like
and how to do it you know very important
items and then we're going to look at
trends and as Craig mentioned earlier
the attacks we'll be looking at will be
trending very typical around the time of
when we deliver the program so they're
going to be the latest things things
that you may not have seen before and
it's going to be very interesting to see
how that really plays out we'll bring in
you know especially in our crisis
communication part of the program which
is going to be handled by Steve Calendar
from the Stanford Business School he's
an expert in this area and we'll tie
that out to the latest SEC regulations
and you can see here what the
participant focus and the concept is
going to be and I think we've we've
recovered many of those things I don't
want to leave a little time here left
for Q&A and discussion so again the key
point of the program this is this is not
high-level compliance this is not about
checking which nist boxes are important
or any of that sort of thing we're going
to go through three stages throughout
the program the pre attack the response
and the recovery and and this is going
to be done in a very real-world way
where teams will form up in the course
and take responsibility for these
various aspects of the response so
communication is going to be key on the
program and how do you do it how do you
talk to it so it's all going to be
virtual we're going to do five sessions
early September for four hours a day we
will we will pace it properly so that we
don't get burned out you know on screens
because now that we've been teaching
things virtually we're very familiar
with what that process looks like and
how it works and you can see the dates
there and one of the things we're going
to ask people to do is to if they can
provide anonymized versions of things
that they'd seen attacks situations
things of that nature that they can
contribute so that will build a database
at Stanford of anonymize you know
information so that this can help others
educate themselves around gee what did
somebody else see and what do I have to
be thinking about and and this also
provides a way for us to do
more directed research at Stanford
around these anonymized kind of attacks
this will this will be extremely
valuable the program will offer a
Stanford certificate of completion very
important and it's of course a
significant amount of effort to go
through the program but highly
worthwhile so here's some information on
how to sign up and Beth did you want to
say anything about these lengths no if
you don't have time - other than if you
don't have time to write this down if
you do though - online dot stanford.edu
and put in cybersecurity this is one of
the courses that will come up and you
should be able to find it there and also
the recording of this webinar will also
be on that signup site as well for
anybody that wants to view any parts of
it again or show it to anyone else all
right
Mike Mike Benin Craig you know great job
the takeaways that you had listed there
I think we're really were really spot-on
a few questions that are sort of grouped
into some various areas for all of you a
question came in you know earlier in the
webinar you had listed a few of the free
attack mitigation strategies and
specifically this person is saying I'm
already overloaded by Kobe 19 with spot
stuff what are the top one or two things
I should focus on right now if you were
going to say from each of you top one
thing that they should do to start
thinking about this so this is Craig I
can start off so on the technical side
it does depend upon how you're set up
and what the impact on the company has
been but but some of the things that
we've seen you know the
that are high loss mechanisms or if you
have migrated significant you know
resources to the cloud identity access
management a data leakage has become a
core issue there and as an area in terms
of you know how you actually access that
system and what the protections are in
that system and and the second one is
it's how you're actually monitoring on
the remote side when you have a mobile
workforce and so again it's dependent on
your situation but these these are a
couple you know of trends that that seem
to be areas of high loss and in good
area spokes and Mike what would you say
there are things yeah yeah so I think
for me response response response is no
matter what controls you have in place
and no matter where you're making your
investments always having a solid
response plan and exercising that
response plan on a regular basis I don't
think you can ever lose from from that
investment so I think that's an area
where I encourage all companies be
focusing on how will they respond and
continuously updating that based on
their profile like lines anything
different than what Craig and Ben have
said well I would only add a lot of the
classic problems are still sitting out
there you know we did some some key
demonstrations risk of loss for some
large auditors last year and you know
you know 20,000 machine network that was
set up that had some miss configurations
in it you know advanced apt attack
vectors were able to take this miss
network down very very quickly and you
know misconfigured systems and not
checking this kind of stuff on a regular
basis so for specifically question came
in for for Craig you had talked about
Robin Hood and crash override Edie
wouldn't be coming next is it going to
be a variant of one of
or they're gonna be something completely
different than Tennessee so that's
that's a great question and and I would
say you've got to watch out for both we
will see variants almost certainly of
what exists today as people fine-tune it
reverse engineering kind of by you know
various groups actually start to
distribute it as as kind of what I call
standard malware that they sell you know
within the criminal infrastructure at
the same time you know Robin Hood was a
reverse engineered nation-state and so
we do keep a very close eye on what's
been stolen and not all of the stolen
malware on the nation-state side yet has
been reverse engineer and so what you're
seeing is as they reverse engineer
different components of that you're
seeing the effect of it and so I think
you need to look at both
you know the commercialization and the
criminal side and the you know the
fine-tuning and adjustment of existing
malware and at the same time it's an and
you need to be looking at you know
what's the likelihood that certain
nation-state malware will be reverse
engineered in the coming year look very
closely at that to understand what the
impact is that will be once it is
reverse in fear so it's a lot more depth
in the India in the bigger course so for
Ben and my clients and this will be the
final question as we wrap up the webinar
what's the most difficult part of cyber
security for a board member or CEO to
understand and what have you found to be
the best ways to try to educate them on
that and these are complex things and
potentially leaders that that that
aren't experts in this area and so what
what are those pieces that are super
difficult for them understanding and
any-any try to any any thoughts on how
to help them understand it no that's an
excellent question I think it's and it's
depend on your board you know I add for
board members on our board and our CEO
CEO understood cyber security
very well that's because him and I had
regular conversations about all the time
one of my board members understood it
fairly well because they're a little bit
more technically adept than maybe the
others were the other ones though
weren't necessarily as technically adept
and so just trying to help them
understand and using very basic examples
and that related back to their personal
lives right securing their personal
information you know when my information
was stolen you know from you know the
federal government sharing that with
them and understand them understand that
the complexity of what this means and
impact to our customers as the utility
at the time as well so I think try to
keep it as simple as possible and that's
why when I was communicating back to our
board I said there's only two numbers I
want you guys focused on which is a
probability of attack and what that the
cost of that attack would be that way
you can just judge up and down the
impact and risks of the company as a
whole and so I try to keep it as simple
as possible I think it's my best message
and I also like the idea of trying to
relate it to personal security because
that's something we've all sort of been
exposed to a little bit and and say look
we're gonna have to take this and take
it to the next level
Lyons any last comment on that earth or
is that good well it did you know we're
out of time but you know as soon as the
directors why even the non-technical
ones understand that 85% of the web
traffic is on the dark web and you can
buy all of Ben's information there right
all right well I just want to say thanks
to all three of you for for for helping
us with this webinar today and I'll turn
it back to Beth blending yes again thank
you to Mike Craig Benjamin and also Mike
lepak for helping with the questions
here at the end and just for this very
informative presentation again thank you
to everybody who joined us today we
appreciate you joining us as a reminder
you'll receive a link to the recording
of the webinar in about a week thank you
very much
you